Real quick before this video begins,
I want to address a few things.
So some of you might be thinking,
man,
this is a lot of overkill.
And to some extent you're right.
This isn't an incredibly intensive
system that I built,
but the reason for it is because I
really believe that time management and
is one of the most important things you
can do.
Pretty much anything in your life is
achievable if you leverage your time in
the right way.
And I just don't think most people,
including myself,
you know,
for a lot of my life,
have a good grip on what we do with our
time and are very intentional with our
time.
So that's kind of the thesis behind this
whole system.
And I think for anyone who's going to
embark on this,
they should have the proper q because it
is kind of a pain to deal with this
sometimes.
But I think you have to know why you're
doing it and kind of like I said,
uh,
in the other video as well.
If you don't like what I do,
please,
please just make your own system.
That's why I made this smorgasborg
system.
As you can see,
this is not some app and it's the reason
I didn't use an app is because of the
fact that nothing was doing quite what I
wanted it to do.
And so I had to make my own system.
So to some extent,
I really believe in kind of doing it
yourself.
So if you have the evening to do that,
go ahead and do that.
All right,
let's get into this video.
All right guys.
So we're going to get into the time
management,
uh,
spreadsheets that I have.
This is a followup to my last video.
So this is for those of you who actually
want to implement this system that I
have.
All right?
So basically this is what it looks like.
It's going to look like this when you
get it,
the first thing you're going to want to
do is you're going to want to think
about your day,
about your life.
You're going to think of one to think
about the types of buckets that you want
to capture.
So for me,
these are the buckets of my life that I
want to capture it miscellaneous just as
anything that's kind of productive,
but two can't really be captured in its
own category.
Like going to the grocery store,
getting a haircut,
something like that.
Waste of time is just a straight up
waste of time and these others are
pretty self explanatory.
Okay.
So I track my time in 16 hour days
because I don't want to spend a ton of
time putting in sleep.
Uh,
I usually sleep from 11:00
PM to 8:00
AM that's usually when I'm sleeping.
So I just consider that that's always,
that's always going to be sleep.
If you want to track the whole time you
can do that.
Uh,
but I would suggest tracking in 16
hours.
It just makes it easier.
If you want to change this time,
you can change it here.
Just change this first row to like 7:00
AM for example.
And all the roads will automatically
change.
Um,
all right,
so the,
after you changed these things over
here,
these,
these buckets,
you're going to want to change them here
as well.
Okay.
Don't change the color because the
colors tied to the macro.
So what's a macro?
It's just a short little piece of code
that helps things go a little smoother.
So to access your macro,
you're going to need change.
A few things.
So you're going to go to options in
excel and then you're going to go to the
customize ribbon page.
You're going to click this developer
tab,
it's just going to let you change some
things you,
you don't need to know that much.
Okay?
So check us out to go to this developer
tab and you go to visual basic.
The one thing that you're going to want
to change is this file path right here.
So whenever you get finished with a day,
you're going to press two buttons,
you're going to press this button,
time management button,
and it's going to count up all the
colors.
So like let's fill in a day real quick.
So let's say when teachers read some
books,
whatever,
miscellaneous,
this is just a sample day here.
Okay,
we were worked out,
blah,
blah.
It took a nap,
whatever.
Okay,
I'm just going to fill it all.
so you finish,
you finish your day and you're going to
hit this time management button.
It's going to track your day.
If the percentages,
here's the total of course,
uh,
and then you're going to go,
if you're in press this button to before
you knew that you don't want to change
this date to whatever your day is.
So if the 26th of April four 26,
this is how I do it,
2017,
it's just going to name it whatever,
whatever's in this first column,
it's just going to name your whole file
that,
so you're going to press this button,
we're not going to press it,
but you're gonna press this button and
it'll change this name to that and it'll
save it in this file path.
But it's a specific file path right
here.
It's,
you're going to go here,
you're going to create a folder that
wherever you want to save your
[inaudible].
I chose time archives,
so like I have this right here.
Time archives.
You can just click this and then you can
just copy it,
control c,
and you just paste it right into here,
right here.
So keep the quotes so that,
uh,
that'll work out for you.
And then,
yeah,
everything else should be good to go.
Don't change the number of buckets,
just try to use the same one if you can,
unless you want to ride your own macro,
which in which case you're finding to
that.
Okay,
so that's pretty much the daily thing.
I think that's,
you press this and then you press that.
Okay.
Alright,
so now we're going to talk a little bit
about the review system.
So here,
let's pull that up.
Okay.
So here's a sample review template.
This one is a lot more free.
You can do a lot more things that,
that if you want,
but I'm going to try to explain how I
use it.
And you can kind of do whatever you
want.
So basically I do two different types of
review systems I do weekly and monthly.
You can do them in bigger or smaller
increments if you want.
So you're basically going to,
just for your own sake,
right?
In what time you're capturing.
So I'll say like four or 26 to let's say
I'm doing next week to uh,
what would next week be,
what do we do from now be four or five
too.
So May,
May 2nd.
That's just so you know what you're
actually capturing.
And so now we're going to ride in.
Let's say I made a video about time
management,
man,
that's like you write all your
achievements,
all the things that you did that were
noteworthy.
Um,
and then you're going to,
and like I said,
you can change this around whatever fits
you.
I'm going to basically summarize your
week in your own words.
How you did this is this is mainly to
get you to think about how your week
went to get you to think about,
do you think you're a productive?
Do you think you weren't?
And you're going to write like major to
do's for the next week.
Uh,
there,
like I said,
you can trace that around if you want.
Then we're going to do this.
This is,
uh,
the most,
this is the part where you actually have
to pay attention.
Okay?
So all you're going to compile your time
from your past days that you've recorded
in the daily spreadsheet.
So like,
let's go to our time archives real
quick.
I'm sorry,
this might take a little bit.
Okay,
so no wonder our time archives,
we're going to open up a bunch of days,
right?
So let's,
let's open up just a few,
just to give you an idea.
We'll open up for days,
but you're going to open up whatever
days your time period is supposed to be
reflecting.
So like,
okay,
let's wait for this trip.
And so for 26 to five,
two,
that's the days I would open up if I
were really doing this.
Okay?
So then you go to those things and all
you're gonna do is you're going to take
in this,
this thing right here.
You know this,
this right here.
And you're going to go back to your few
template.
You're going to paste that in right
here.
Just like,
so you're going to go to your next,
you're going to close that out.
I'm going to go to your next day and
you're going to do the exact same thing,
blah,
blah.
You're just going to pace right down the
row.
Okay,
let's just do three days for example.
Um,
okay,
so whatever.
So you have these three days,
you're going to want to like put them
down like this,
making sure there's no space between
them.
That's just how I read the macro.
Like I said,
if you,
if you know anything about VBA,
you can change this all to suit you,
but then you're just going to press
compile time sheets and it's going to
summarize it,
right gear going to tell you how many
hours total you have,
a percentage of your day that you spend
on each thing and the number of hours
you did do anything.
That's pretty much it.
Uh,
this'll give you basically the snapshot
look of Your Week.
You can graph this is if you want to get
like a better,
more like a better way to look at your
data.
But anyway,
that's just up to you.
So anyway,
then you're going to save it.
So I'll show you what I do like month
one,
review data or week one,
blah,
week to et cetera.
So yeah,
that's about it.
Uh,
and then I just,
yeah,
I just save it by hand.
So if you need any more help with these,
these spreadsheets,
sure.
To comment,
let me know or whatnot.
Review the video if you don't understand
anything.
One thing I wanted to mention real quick
guys is let's say that you did not fill
in something for your day.
This happens to me occasionally where
I'll just forget I'm doing something
else in busy.
You know,
what have you,
what do you do?
Okay.
You want to go back in,
don't give yourself a hard time,
just fill in generally what you did,
just ballpark it.
But,
uh,
the point is,
is to get,
is to try not to miss any days.
So even if you have to just estimate,
um,
and I think that will do really well.
So that's just something practical that
I've had to come to grips with.
And sometimes you just,
you forget you're doing something else,
you just have to estimate it.
It's okay.
The point is,
is to build up over time,
just this grand view of,
uh,
of what your time is looking like.
And on the grand scheme of things,
it's still will be pretty accurate.
So yeah.
Anyway.
Okay,
guys,
thanks for watching.